20 ans chapeau et redingote tels que
nous les restitue après un siècle ce
film miraculeusement conservés par les
archives de la planète
les socialistes ont l'air contents
presque radieux et pourtant si l'on fait
le voyage de tours si l'on loué la salle
du manège c'est pour divorce
leur parti la sf you va se déchirer et
donner naissance au parti communiste
la guerre mondiale de 1914 à 1918 et la
révolution bolchévique depuis 1917 ont
rendu cette séparation inévitable
le congrès va durer quatre jours c'est
assez pour se disputer sur le présent et
l'avenir
pour se souvenir aussi du temps jadis où
il était camarades à la vie à la mort
prouver par jean jaurès parti trop tôt
[Musique]
la ffu était né en 1905 depuis cette
date et jusqu'à 1914 c'est jaurès qui
l'avait fait pas tout seul évidemment le
parti comptait d'autres dirigeants
d'envergure
mais c'est lui qui les avait unis qui
était parvenu à retenir ensemble les
tendances divergentes du socialisme
français
jaurès avait fait marcher d'un même pas
les anciens de la commune et des
marxistes ceux qui prenaient
l'insurrection
et ceux qui ne croyaient qu'on syndicats
avec un idéal
c'est un parti aux objectifs théoriques
révolutionnaire serre que dans ses
statuts il se définit comme un parti de
lutte de classe et de révolution et son
objectif est de remplacer la société
capitaliste par une société communiste
il est certain qu'en 1914 ce qui
distingue un socialiste d'un radical par
exemple ce sont deux grandes formations
de la gauche c'est que les socialistes
pensent que l'avenir de la société
appartient à une propriété sociale des
moyens de production échanges quelle que
soit la manière dont ce devrait se
passer les transitions quelle que soit
la manière dont se réorganiser cette
société aux collectives cet idéal
collectiviste et partagée par tous les
partis socialistes européens ils sont
réunis au sein d'une organisation
militante la deuxième internationale
elle est le fer de lance de l'opposition
à la guerre qui menace régulièrement
d'éclater entre la france et l'allemagne
pour éviter le conflit jaurès à une
solution en cas de déclaration de guerre
il faut que les deux partis socialistes
l'allemand et le français s'unissent
pour appelé ensemble à la grève générale
ouvrière
mais cette résolution évoqué à tous les
congrès de l'international n'est jamais
adoptée qui ait jamais adopté pour une
raison bien simple c'est que les
social-démocraties germanique ne veulent
pas ni les austro hongrois lit les
allemands ne veulent entendre parler
d'une politique spécifique de
l'internationale socialiste qui
voudraient empêcher la guerre et ils ne
sont pas les seuls dans le parti
français jules guesde et bien d'autres
considèrent qu'il s'agit de billevesées
théorique et dangereuse dangereuse parce
que qu'est ce que ça voudrait signifier
ça voudrait dire que on ferait quasiment
un appel à la désobéissance alors que la
guerre menacerait mais dans ce cas là si
ça marche eh bien le pays où les
sociétés serait plus fort ce répit le
plus désorganisé donc c'est le pays le
plus réactionnaire sous-entendu un pays
aussi barbare que la russie qui pourrait
l'emporter ça fait très peur aux
sociaux-démocrates sa demande ça fait
peur aussi aux socialistes français et
guen n'est pas du tout sur la même ligne
que jaurès
pour se faire entendre des militants et
des sympathisants
jaurès signe tous les jours un éditorial
dans l'humanité le journal qu'il a
fondée en 1914 l'humanité d'hier à des
centaines de milliers d'exemplaires à la
mesure du poids électoral de la sf
fillon
avec 100 députés au parlement le parti
et le deuxième de france et il est en
progression constante
[Musique]
fin juillet à 14 la menace de guerre
surgi à nous
jaurès en conformité avec ses
engagements se lance à corps perdu dans
une tentative pour conjurer la
catastrophe
dans la semaine décisive il multiplie
les entrevues et les meetings avec les
dirigeants des partis socialistes
européens
tout en continuant à écrire chaque jour
son papier dans l'humanité
la guerre semble inévitable mais jaurès
continue de s'accrocher à la paix
le 31 juillet il publie ce qui restera
son dernier article
ce qui importe avant tout c'est la
continuité de l'action c'est le
perpétuel éveil de la pensée et de la
conscience ouvrière là est la vraie
sauvegarde là est la garantie de
l'avenir
[Musique]
si j'aurai ce 31 juillet dean au café du
croissant avant d'écrire son article
décisif c'est aussi parce que après
avoir rencontré les autres partis à
bruxelles l'avant veille il attend de
savoir ce que vont faire exactement les
allemands
jaurès ne rencontrera personnes
il n'écrira plus d'articles
ce 31 juillet vers 22 heures sous les
yeux effarés de ses proches
collaborateurs il tombe sous les balles
tirées à bout portant par un militant
nationaliste
[Musique]
ed également arrivera mais après la mort
de jaurès et il arrivera avec une
réponse qui toute façon d'une réponse
négative des sociaux démocrates
allemands étaient décidés à ne rien
faire concrètement contre la
mobilisation allemande qui répondait à
la mobilisation russe pourquoi parce que
les allemands considéré que c'était les
russes qui provoquait de conflit avec
cette mobilisation générale est que face
au danger d'invasion us et bien les
allemands étaient dans l'obligation de
se défendre
tout va très vite maintenant car le jeu
des alliances militaires provoque un
enchaînement inexorable trois jours
après la mort de jaurès la france lié
par son traité d'alliance avec la russie
est en guerre avec l'allemagne
l'opposition des socialistes est
emportée comme un fétu de paille
ils veulent sincèrement empêcher la
guerre au moment où ils se rendent
compte qu'ils n'y arrivent pas ils
considèrent que leur pays est attaqué
alors les allemands considèrent aussi
clair il est attaqué donc eu tout le
monde tout le monde et le défenseur en
fête est donc là ce moment là il se
rallie effectivement majoritairement aux
principes de la défense nationale mais
finalement parce que les événements sont
allées vite parce qu'ils sont mal
préparés parce que la conception de
l'internationalisme et plus théorisé
assez peu clair donc de ce flou en fait
va ressortir une position défense
nationale mais effectivement la défense
nationale elle va être symbolisé par les
obsèques de jaurès c'est ce qui est
encore peut-être plus beau plus poignant
bon que certains peuvent trouver
peut-être même que révoltant mais enfin
aux plus trash indies on sait qu'un du
shakespeare c'est que
celui qui un quart des adultes contre la
guerre sécheresse et ce sont ses
obsèques qui c'est l'union sacrée et ça
se fait effectivement très naturellement
viviani va par le président du conseil
va parler aux obsèques des chats des le
président de la chambre des députés rend
hommage à jaurès il ya des discours de
tous les dirigeants socialistes de
l'international
les funérailles de jaurès se déroule
alors que les soldats mobilisés traverse
paris au son des fifres et du vivat des
foules
la propagande officielle promet une
guerre fraîche et joyeuse l'humeur
générale les franchement belliqueuse
[Applaudissements]
en fin d'après midi tous les députés
debout vote à l'unanimité les crédits de
guerre et la centaine de socialistes qui
par principe anti bourgeois ne venait
jamais le budget le fond cette fois sans
sourciller avant la guerre évidemment
les socialistes ne votaient pas les
budgets là il s'agit pas seulement de
votre budget il s'agit de voter les
crédits de guerre mais les socialistes
estiment qu'ils ne votent pas les
crédits de guerre ils estiment qu'ils
votent les crédits de défense nationale
et tout est dans la terminologie on voit
bien en tout cas dans le milieu
politique socialiste et 99 9 % des gens
en france l'idée que bon les allemands
nous attaque nous nous défendons ça
s'impose
effectivement naturellement soit qu'il
soit même besoin de se concerter ou de 2
ou de délibéré c'est une réaction
unanime
pour les français les trois premières
semaines sont effroyables le feu
allemand est dévastateur on compte
trente mille morts et plus de cent mille
disparus les troupes françaises sont
contraintes d'opérer une gigantesque
retraites
le 27 août les avant-postes allemand
bivouac à 28 km de paris
et c'est dans ce contexte de d'invasion
effectivement les socialistes sont
amenés à prendre une vraie à avoir une
réponse inédite il faut qu'il y ait une
représentation des socialistes au
gouvernement il gouvernement le
considère aussi que la situation est
tellement dangereuse qu'il faut être sûr
que la classe ouvrière dans les usines
etc et quartier ouvrier reste bien sûr
une ligne de défense nationale
donc jules guesde et marcel sembat font
leur entrée au gouvernement
avant 14 les socialistes refuser par
principe d'être les ministres d'un
gouvernement bourgeois jules guesde avec
sa barbe de patriarche s'était toujours
montré le plus intransigeant sur la
question
[Musique]
la nomination comme ministre d'état sans
portefeuille de l'introducteur du
marxisme en france et fait remarquer les
esprits
marcel sembat un proche de jaurès est
nommé ministre des travaux publics il a
la tâche redoutable d'assurer la
circulation des marchandises et des
ressources dans un pays en guerre c'est
le ministre du charbon et en avril 1915
un autre socialiste albert thomas qui
n'avait jamais caché son ambition
ministérielle et nommé sous-secrétaire
d'état à la production
très concrètement il est en charge de se
mettre en contact avec les industriels
puisque la production d'armements repose
sur une économie mixte de guerre donc
l'état qui passent des contrats avec les
industriels donc il faut les mettre
autour de la table est passé des
contrats avec eux et surtout ce qui
n'est pas une mince affaire trouver des
hommes et des femmes pour les faire
travailler dans les usines donc il a une
mission absolument stratégiques surtout
dans un contexte de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre puisque les hommes dans la
force de l'âge sont au front
il faut attendre le début de 1915 pour
que les voies d'une poignée de
dissidents socialistes opposés à la
défense nationale ce vaste entendre
il ya des socialistes qui considèrent
qu'on va trop loin dans l'union sacrée
que peut-être on aurait on aurait dû
voter les crédits de guerre mais
peut-être pas rentrer au gouvernement
surtout qu'on est rentré au gouvernement
sans contrepartie donc que font ces
ministre socialiste dans le gouvernement
alors qu'ils n'obtiennent aucune mesure
socialiste que fait jules guesde qui n'a
même pas de portefeuille dont la
présence est purement symbolique donc
une opposition à certains points de
l'union sacrée plus qu'à toute l'union
sacrée c'est une remise en cause oui de
la censure de la suspension du parlement
pendant les premiers mois de la guerre
donc l'idée qu' on est plus en
démocratie plus de liberté de réunion
puis liberté de la presse donc c'est à
la fois contre la guerre contre le
gouvernement de guerre contre ce que les
socialistes font au sein de ce
gouvernement c'est assez à ses multiples
en fait
c'est la réunion désimeur valdes en
suisse au bas de septembre 1915 qui
sonne l'heure du grand ralliement
alors oui mais en valdes en fait vient
de la conjonction de différents courants
du parti socialiste des pays neutres qui
ne comprennent pas ce qui se passe ou ne
comprennent pas ce que font les partis
socialistes des pays belligérants et
donc qui appelle à ce que l'on fasse une
conférence pour rappeler à l'ordre leur
caméra de des pays en guerre en disant
mais enfin on a voté des résolutions
ensemble dans l'international
les délégués à la réunion des humeurs
valdes sont peu nombreux mais ça n'a pas
d'importance ce qui compte est ce qui
fait scandale
c'est qu'en pleine guerre et alors que
leurs soldats se massacrent mutuellement
tous les jours des français et des
allemands se concertent librement
pourparlers de paix
les délégués français sont des militants
venus de la base est parfaitement
inconnu en revanche le délégué allemand
georg les deux bourgs est un membre
éminent de l'international familier de
jaurès
parmi les autres participants deux
russes bientôt célèbre lénine et trotsky
c'est d'ailleurs trotsky qui rédige le
manifeste de la conférence véritable
réquisitoire contre la guerre et la
trahison des appareils socialiste nous
nous sommes réunis pour renouer les
liens brisés de l'international nous
appelons la classe ouvrière à reprendre
conscience d'elle-même à lutter pour la
paix une paix sans occupation ni
annexion sans assujettissement
économique respectant le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux-mêmes
prolétaires de tous les pays
unissez-vous et les mérovingiens
considération lutter contre toute forme
de patriotisme et que voilà la france a
vocation à disparaître comme tous les
états dans la société de l'avenir la
société socialiste ou communiste où il y
aura plus de frontières nationales ni
d'état les frontières est essentielle si
les frontières entre les classes
sociales
en france au sein de la sf you c'est un
instituteur totalement inconnu ferment
loriot qui se fait le défenseur des
thèses de zimmer valdes
là on va le retrouver au premier congrès
tenu par le parti socialiste pendant la
guerre on descend 1915 wii prend la
parole c'est la première fois qu'il
prend la parole au congrès national du
parti socialiste et il critique les
ministres socialistes on n'a rien à
faire dans ce gouvernement et quand il
dit ça à la tribune du congrès face à
lui parmi les délégués du congrès il ya
les ministres qui sont là et qui lui
répondent donc la confrontation aller
direct c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
assez fort parce que les militants
savent que ils se font interdire des
réunions par un vote du conseil des
ministres avec des ministres socialiste
qui vote pour cette interdiction des
militants peuvent être emprisonnés
arrêté
loriot va être déplacé d'office en tant
qu'instituteur pour pour pour le
sanctionner pour son action
face à cette minorité pacifiste encore
embryonnaire les majoritaires de guerre
assument leurs positions sans complexe
la gigantesque bataille de verdun qui
commence en février 1916 renforce même
leur détermination à obtenir la victoire
totale sur l'ennemi allemand
albert thomas chargé de la production
des armes au sein du gouvernement se
dépensent sans compter
depuis son ministère thomas est en
liaison constante avec la fine fleur du
patronat français
[Musique]
il passe avec les industriels des
contrats de production pharaonique
il détonne et on lui reprochera
justement il est le ministre de
l'armement ce que les communistes
appellerons péjorativement le ministre
des obus c'est pas n'importe quelle
place c'est lui qui est responsable de
la boucherie industrielle
et il s'implique tellement qu'ils
délaissent quand même en partie les
relations avec l'ail sefyu il est de
plus en plus éloignés du parti de plus
en plus éloignés des militants quelqu'un
comme albert thomas on voit bien que la
guerre c'est aussi l'occasion de tenter
de nouvelles expériences de nouvelles
manières de mobiliser pays de réfléchir
à ce que peut être le rôle de l'état
dans une économie moderne en travaillant
avec les syndicats ouvriers en
travaillant avec des patrons
quand ils ne fréquentent pas les patrons
albert-thomas pour les usines afin de
porter la bonne parole sur le thème de
ses harangues produire produire produire
pour la défense nationale et la victoire
[Musique]
la première guerre mondiale c'est aussi
l'entrée vraiment de l'état dans la
gestion des affaires économiques c'est
un rêve socialiste en fait c'est gérer
l'économie de la société donc pour lui
il y voit un tremplin pour construire
une nouvelle économie qui pourra
perdurer après guerre ils y voient le
moyen de pousser la nationalisation des
chemins de fer de pousser la
nationalisation des mines de charbon un
des éléments stratégiques de la nation
il est persuadé de faire du socialisme
même si bien sûr il est quand même
soumis aux injonctions de productivité
qui contribua complètement faire sauter
la législation du travail qui existaient
jusque là à augmenter considérablement
les heures de travail des mains d'oeuvre
dans les usines donc c'est ambivalent
[Musique]
mais malgré l'effort industriel la
victoire ne vient pas les hommes sont
braves mais ils ont épuisé sacrifiés
et cette guerre qui dure trop longtemps
à raison de la belle unité de la sf you
d'avant 14 dès la fin 2009 116 le parti
de jaurès et fractionné en trois camps
à droite celui des partisans acharnés de
la guerre patriotique qui détiennent
toujours la majorité au centre une
minorité grandissante représente déjà
presque un tiers du parti elle refuse d
excès de l'union sacrée et tout en
votant les crédits de guerre elle prône
l'ouverture de négociations de paix à
gauche enfin les images valent bien
commence à gagner du terrain en
affirmant une opposition totale à la
guerre
les trois tendances qui se poseront à
tours en 1920 sont déjà fixés
c'est alors que surgit l'événement qui
va achever de les rendre
irréconciliables
au mois de mars 1917 les soldats russes
du front se mutinent ils sont excédés
d'avoir le ventre vide d'être mal armées
et mal commandes
[Musique]
les ouvriers des grandes villes se
soulèvent également en quelques jours le
tsar nicolas ii et contraint d'abdiquer
les socialistes français qui voyait en
lui un ennemi à abattre sont
naturellement content
[Musique]
la russie devient une république que
rêver de mieux on était quand même un
petit peu gêné jusqu'à présent de se
dire qu'à côté de la france et de
l'angleterre la russie tsariste duris
d'autres alliés etc c'est quand même un
petit peu gênant bah écoutez tout va
bien tout va bien maintenant c'est
devenu une république démocratique
libéral ya même des socialistes qui vont
entrer au gouvernement ces parfaites
mais le poème c'est qu'ils seront tous
contents pour des raisons totalement
différentes voire opposées les
majoritaires de guerre considère que
comme les arts isme a été abattu c'est
la république en russie donc les soldats
vont se battre pour la république keller
république donc finalement ça va
renforcer l'effort de guerre les hivers
valdahon l'analyse exactement opposée il
considère que cette révolution c'est le
début de la fin de la guerre qu'en ayant
renversé le gouvernement harris tu es
belle voilà donc le refaire la même
chose dans tous les autres pays et comme
ça on mettra fin à la guerre
dans l'histoire ce sont les émerveille
bien qu'ils ont le nez fin
les soldats russes ne veulent plus se
battre du tout
en ville leurs délégués peuple les
soviets c'est grande assemblée
permanente vibrante de passion
révolutionnaire
les soviets de soldats et d'ouvriers
travaillent et par les mines tendance du
socialisme russe forme déjà un pouvoir
parallèle à côté du gouvernement
provisoire
et au mois d'avril lénine en personne
rentre d'exil il est déterminé à jeter
de l'huile sur le feu
bientôt les soviets réclame la paix
immédiate
des gouvernants français anglais italien
s'en inquiète il décide donc d'envoyer
des émissaires
socialiste qui pourront s'adresser aux
goûts aux membres socialistes du
gouvernement provisoire russe et bien
sûr on choisit donc albert thomas son
objectif c'est de dire il faut continuer
la guerre avec nous vous êtes même si
vous changez vous êtes nos alliés il
faut continuer la guerre
[Musique]
et
donc son argument c'est de dire vous
avez renversé le tsar de moscou
continuer cette guerre qui est une
guerre démocratique et renversé les deux
stars de berlin et de vienne
pendant son voyage il ya quantité
d'articles en france albert thomas est
en russie il visite les usines la guerre
va repartir l'alliance est maintenue etc
[Musique]
mais le désir d'albert thomas ne seront
pas exaucés à la fin du mois d'octobre
17 les bolchéviks conduit par les nih
s'empare du pouvoir sur un programme de
socialisme intégral bientôt désigné sous
le mot de communisme
lénine et trotsky sont des radicaux
au mois de février 1918 il si une paix
immédiate avec les allemands et retire
unilatéralement l'armée russe du conflit
les socialistes français attachés à la
défense nationale sont fous de rage
la guerre va durer encore 7 mois jusqu'à
la victoire de la france et de ses
alliés au mois de novembre 1918
[Musique]
gr
pourtant à l'image de la france
victorieuse mais exemple la est si fier
au sort dévastée du conflit plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de militants et de
sympathisants sont morts sur le champ de
bataille la jeunesse du parti
ceux qui ont survécu sont pour la
plupart remonté contre les dirigeants
qui ont soutenu quatre ans durant la
politique de défense nationale
en plus à partir de début de l'année
1919 les soldats socialiste qui commence
à être démobilisés donc ils reviennent
certains qui ont été blessés qu'ont vécu
des expériences traumatisantes et donc
il ya une hostilité vis-à-vis des
anciens majoritaire de guerre qui est
très très nette qui va pas du tout
s'atténuer qui même va en se renforçant
en fait parti socialiste a beaucoup plus
adhérent 1919 qui n'en avait en 1914
c'est effectivement des gens très
souvent qu'ils ne veulent plus connaître
la guerre qui n'est pas forcément que
des anciens combattants ça peut y avoir
ici les gens les jeunes mais qui sont
traumatisés parce que la guerre a marqué
le village la vie la famille donc il y a
une inspiration très forte à autre chose
au changement phare 1918 albert thomas
et les tenants de la défense nationale
perdre enfin la majorité mieux que ça il
s'effondre au profit du courant
centriste dirigé par jean longuet le
petit fils de karl marx la nouvelle
majorité de la et ses filles au était
hétéroclite sur sa droite longuet a reçu
le renfort d'anciens partisans de la
guerre parmi eux léon blum qui se fait
connaître en rédigeant la motion de
soutien à longuet
marcel cachin cadres chevronnés
l'orateur favori des meetings d'ouvriers
qui reçoit un récompense la direction de
l'humanité et ludovic frossard qui est
nommé secrétaire général du parti
puisque longuet ne veut pas du poste sur
sa gauche les images valent bien lui ont
apporté leur soutien du bout des lèvres
ils sont toujours menées par
l'instituteur fernand loriot et par
boris souvarine qui a combattu dans les
tranchées et qui a perdu son frère aîné
c'est leur tendance qui a désormais le
vent en poupe il regarde résolument vers
l'est vers le pays des travailleurs que
lénine et les bolchéviques sont en train
de bâtir un peu un peu l'image de ce
pays où les ouvriers ont pris le pouvoir
le pouvoir appartient aux soviets tous
les travailleurs que son pouvoir le
peuple est au pouvoir ah c'est la
formule de jules romains l'alleud a
relevé à l'est ça vobis inspire
confiance de plus en plus de gens à
l'intérieur du socialisme et qu'on a
envie de penser que ça se passe bien et
bolcheviques eux sont persuadés un os
dès 1917 et puis encore au début des
années 20 que la révolution russe n'est
que le début d'une révolution mondiale
ça ils partagent cet orient cette
orientation avec los rios souvarine etc
lénine est persuadé que si la révolution
russe reste seul va s'effondrer et que
les difficultés qu'ils rencontrent en
russie les problèmes qu'ils ont
s'effaceront avec le développement de la
révolution mondiale
la révolution parti de moscou se propage
en europe en 1919 les insurrections
révolutionnaire d'inspiration
bolchévique ont lieu en allemagne et
angles
[Musique]
à berlin comme à budapest des soviets
d'ouvriers de soldats temps de prendre
le pouvoir selon le modèle prôné par les
murs
ils durent quelques semaines avant
d'être écrasée dans le sang
[Musique]
la france quant à elle est secoué par
une vague de grève massive et durable
les mots d'ordre sont le plus souvent
ouvertement révolutionnaire
donc cette vague de grèves des grèves
offensives souvent victorieuse renforce
chez les militants révolutionnaires
l'idée que la révolution mondiale non
seulement est en cours mais qu'elles
arrivent en france que ces grèves là
vont s'étendre et donner la possibilité
de former des conseils ouvriers 1 comme
en allemagne en russie et ses conseils
ouvriers vont prendre le pouvoir et
c'est comme ça qu'on va mettre en place
le socialisme le communisme
[Musique]
alors c'est difficile à déterminer mais
dans la population qui travaille en
france c'est évident que la majorité
n'est pas partisan d'une révolution en
1919 1920 il ya une minorité importante
qui est là dessus mais si la majorité
avaient déballé c'est vrai il y aurait
une révolution donc là le store ou terry
aurait été différente et sai
s'illusionne sans doute un peu sur ce
point là
en novembre 1919 ont lieu les premières
élections législatives depuis 1914 les
socialistes font taire leurs divisions
ils n'ont pas le choix tout le monde est
contre eux ils sont désignés comme
l'ennemi absolu
antipatriotes sanguinaire partageux
démagogues pour bien faire le
gouvernement a concocté une loi
électorale qui leur est très défavorable
le quand il ya des élections à la fin de
l'année certes les socialistes
obtiennent plus de voix que ce qu'ils
obtenu en 1914 mais ils ont aussi comme
tous les autres se sont coalisés contre
une trentaine de députés en moins donc
hyper d'à peu près le tiers de roues
parlementaire et puis au fond c'est pas
non plus le raz-de-marée des
raz-de-marée c'est à dire qu'il passe en
gros de 18 à quelque chose comme 22 ou
23 % face à la toujours des dissidents
et tout dépend comment comment qui on
compte exactement chez les uns et chez
les autres mais ils gagnent quelques
points on peut dire qu après un tel
traumatisme après un tel événement
cinq ans et puis une guerre mondiale et
d'une famille ont 300 morts c'est pas
non plus le raz-de-marée gigantesque
la chambre élue est la plus à droite de
la troisième république c'est la chambre
bleu horizon les conservateurs se
sentent légitimés pour agir sans
faiblesse contre les révolutionnaires
il faut dire que la tendance radicale
des partisans de lénine représente
maintenant plus de 40% dans la et ses
filles
fernand loriot et boris souvarine qui
sont les animateurs de cette tendance
sont donc jetés en prison
et sont accusées dans un premier temps
de mener un anarchiste est aussi de
complot contre la sûreté de l'état
bon alors effectivement ils disent mais
enfin nous on peut renverser l'état mais
on a toujours voulu renverser l'état
enfin depuis qu'on est militant et
loriot sur sa carte d'adhérent de la
session où il y met enfin moi je suis
allé en haïti shop 1905 on a toujours
proclamé qu'on voulait renverser le
système capitaliste et le renverser par
une société communiste il y aurait de
nouveau
donc mais finalement ils seront
d'ailleurs à quitter un ce qui est la
preuve qu' il n'y avait rien de
consistant derrière mais enfin ils vont
passer près d'un an en prison et ça va
avoir une importance fondamentale parce
qu'ils vont rater le congrès de tours en
décembre 1920 où ils sont encore
emprisonnés donc c'est un emprisonnement
qui est câble qui a des conséquences
tout à fait concrète et pratique sur les
congrès du mouvement ouvrier de 2 cette
année là où quelques semaines avant leur
arrestation
loriot et souvarine ont obtenu que la et
ses filles au kit la deuxième
internationale qui n'a pas su s'opposer
à la guerre il milite pour que le parti
adhère à la troisième qui vient tout
juste d'être créée par les bolcheviks
marcel cachin et frossard sont envoyés
par le parti socialiste en fait en
russie pour négocier avec les bolcheviks
une éventuelle reconstruction de
l'international autour de la troisième
internationale mais aussi d'autres
partis qui n'y sont pas aucun mandat en
fait un peu assez floue et quand ils
arrivent ils se rendent bien compte que
c'est pas du tout ce que veulent les
bolchéviques des bolcheviks eux ils
veulent construire leur internationale
communiste sur leurs bases enfin sur les
bases qu'ils ont qui s'estiment est
juste évidemment les bases définies par
nine et puis ses collaborateurs et ils
ne veulent pas d'une négociation
internationale ils veulent simplement
peu qu'on les rejoigne
[Musique]
à
chacun voit en fait que le parti va
aller à la troisième internationale
cachin il faut ça ils sont allés pendant
l'été à moscou ont depuis la russie a
lancé en août 1920 qu'ils étaient
partisans d'accepter les conditions
d'adhésion à l'internationale communiste
[Applaudissements]
le voici frossard descendant les marches
afin de rejoindre cachan et zinovyev le
patron de la troisième internationale
pour la photo de famille
en recommandant l'adhésion
les deux compères ont fourni aux
socialistes français un vrai motif de
séparation
il faut trancher en convoquant un
congrès extraordinaire ce sera à tour
dans cinq mois
[Musique]
25 décembre 1920 l'heure de la
séparation a sonné les principaux ténors
du parti sont là blum frossard cash à un
longue et les autres ils ont fourbi
leurs armes et préparer leurs arguments
pour ou contre l'adhésion à la troisième
internationale qui impose aux postulants
vingt-et-une conditions préalables en
fait les vingt-et-une conditions sont
pensés par les bolcheviks pour trier un
peu les socialistes qui veulent rentrer
dans la troisième internationale ils ont
un peu l'impression qu'ils vont être
submergé par ces socialistes qui veulent
adhérer que ça sera plus vraiment leur
international donc les vingt-et-une
conditions sont là pour mettre un verrou
la porte 1 comme le 19e donc assez clair
assez strictes et conditions les plus
difficiles à accepter pour les
socialistes français ce sont les
conditions qui prévoit un mot discipline
très centralisé qu'on appellera plus
tard le centralisme démocratique
qui
sont quand même en rupture avec la
tradition je dirais de discussion
justement de confrontation qui était la
tradition politique française
parmi les plus controversées de ses
ventes et une condition la discipline de
fer et
jg de tous les militants la tutelle du
parti sur les syndicats l'obligation
d'exécuter toutes les décisions de
l'international ou encore de soutenir
sans réserve l'union soviétique
s'est bâti une condition suscite quand
même
des oppositions des perplexités il
semble que les bolcheviks et mal saisies
qu'ils imposaient aux autres partis et
donc il ya certaines conditions qui
coince un peu donc ça les partisans
français de la troisième internationale
se rendent bien compte et donc ils
disent bien le congrès tour ne doit pas
se prononcer pour ou contre le maintien
de conditions c'est pas ça la question
la question c'est à quel international
on adhère
[Musique]
léon blum rejette cette interprétation
pour lui les vingt-et-une conditions
sont bel et bien le passage obligé d'une
adhésion qu'il rejette en bloc car elles
forment dit il un ensemble doctrinal
cohérent qui porte en lui un système de
dictature permanente
au centre jean longuet est arrivé à
tours avec l'idée que les socialistes
français pourront faire leur choix parmi
les vingt-et-une conditions les
bolchéviques auquel la tiédeur et la
modération de longuè font horreur vont
lui faire comprendre qu'il se bercent
d'illusions
depuis moscou zinovyev le grand patron
de la troisième internationale en
personne envoie un télégramme à
l'intention des congressistes réunis à
tours jean longueuil il est qualifié
d'agent de l' influence bourgeoise sur
le prolétariat
longuet piqué au vif monte à la tribune
pour dénoncer une internationale limitée
fragmenté et sectaire mais le coup a
porté il ne s'en remettra pas
[Musique]
depuis la tribune blum déclare que
l'offensé faite à longuet est
révélatrice
pour imposer sa tutelle au futur parti
communiste moscou n'hésitera pas à
utiliser les insultes ou la calomnie
l'expression libre d'opinions
contradictoires n'aura plus cours
blomet prophétique il prédit que les
bolchéviques étoufferont leurs partisans
français avant de les transformer en
marionnettes obéissante et il affirme
qu'il n'a pas de leçon de révolution à
recevoir je ne connais pas deux espèces
de socialisme dont l'un serait
révolutionnaire et dont l'autre ne le
serait pas je ne connais que le
socialisme révolutionnaire qui mène à
une transformation totale du régime de
la propriété et la révolution c'est par
définition cette transformation même
bloom va donner un discours à tours qui
aborde beaucoup de questions importantes
du moment alors on est d'accord ou pas
avec ce qu'ils défendent mais en fait en
tout cas il prend position sur les
questions importantes de leurs il ya
deux questions sur les qualifs et
l'impasse d'une part sur l'opposition
entre socialisme réformiste et
socialistes révolutionnaires il a une
position extrêmement curieuse dans son
discours à toury d'il ya plus réformiste
dans le parti ça n'existe pas on est
tous révolutionnaire mais alors ce qui
alors que lui était réformiste c'est
assez évident mais bon ces questions là
est totalement occulté et la deuxième
question c'est l'expérience de guerre
alors ça c'est tout à fait
caractéristique puisque l'huile et qui
était directeur de cabinet de marcel
sembat donc appris par cette
participation socialiste au gouvernement
n'en dit pas un mot lors de son discours
c'est une question qui est totalement
mis sous le tapis il manque
d'une quelque chose de concret sur ben
voilà qu'est ce qu'on a fait dans le
passé qu'est ce qu'on fera à l'avenir
pour l'ailé gauche du parti l'avenir est
déjà là à moscou
marcel cachin qui dirige l'humanité
déploie tous ses talents d'orateur pour
convaincre que seule la troisième
internationale ouvre la voie à la vraie
révolution communiste il est
religieusement écouté
le fait est là la république social est
établi à moscou ce fait immense de la
révolution russe doit être camarades
constamment présent à nos pensées il
doit à mon sens dominé les esprits de
tous
quand mme blum critique le parti de
petits soldats au garde à vous cachin
réplique qu'il est bien de constituer un
parti vigoureux et fortement disciplinée
pour faire la révolution que les russes
l'ont fait chez eux qu'ils ont donné
l'exemple qu'il faut suivre
si cachin défend la notion que loriot et
sous marines les deux y merval liens
historiques ont rédigé c'est parce que
ces deux derniers sont toujours détenus
à la santé les deux prisonniers savent
pourtant et les congressistes aussi que
marcel cachin a été jusqu'en 1917 un
partisan enthousiaste de la défense
nationale c'est le moment ou jamais de
faire son autocritique
cachin est obligé en fait à un moment de
faire amende honorable sinon il pourrait
pas être accepté dans le parti qui avait
adhéré à la troisième internationale
dont qui perdrait la direction de
l'humanité donc à un moment il est
obligé de faire contrition et de dire je
vous demande pardon pour la position
qu'on a prises pendant la guerre et
c'est que c'est des volailles s'est
trompé se trompera beaucoup par la suite
aussi changera beaucoup d'orientation
bon après il est loin d'être le seul et
beaucoup de militants à la base qui
avaient voté pour les majoritaires de
guerre en 1915 1916 par exemple ont
totalement changé de vote
en considérant que voilà on peut faire
le bilan de cette expérience là et ce
bilan est négatif et c'est parce que ces
militants change d'orientation change de
vote que la motion larrieu souvarine au
congrès tour peut obtenir presque 70%
des suffrages sinon ça serait pas
possible c'est bien parce que des
militants change de courant que le
rapport de force change totalement dans
le parti
le 29 décembre 1920
l'adhésion à la troisième internationale
y voter le divorce est prononcé
la s et fils et section française de
l'internationale communiste est née elle
se rebaptisera bientôt parti communiste
devant ce raz-de-marée léon blum
s'incline déclare au vainqueur nous
garderons la vieille maison pendant que
vous irez courir laventure
dans le partage des biens les perdants
conserve le nom de et c'est fillon mais
ce sont les communistes qui garde pour
l'humanité le journal fondé par jaurès
[Musique]
la gauche est désormais divisé et c'est
définitif les communistes se réjouissent
de s'être séparé des tièdes les
socialistes eux sont persuadé d'incarner
le socialisme authentique ce que dit
d'ailleurs les anglos me congrès tour
c'est que on espère que vous reviendrez
vers nous on garde la vieille maison
qu'un espère que in fine et vous
reviendrez vers ce socialisme qui doit
être le socialisme d origine donc
théoriquement cette main tendue allez
toujours là sauf que assez rapidement il
voit effectivement que les positions
sont en train de se durcir du côté
communiste
comme blum l'avait prévu très vite
l'union soviétique s'empare de la sf ici
pour en faire sa chose dans le cadre du
jeu géostratégique mené par la russie
souvarine et loriot qui avaient pourtant
été les plus fervents partisans de la
troisième internationale rejette cette
tutelle
ils sont exclus du parti immédiatement
dès 1924 la mainmise du kremlin se
durcit staline devenu l'homme fort du
régime après la mort de lénine choisi
les dirigeants du parti français impose
la stratégie les mots d'ordre et les
anathèmes
[Musique]
ils sont traités de social fasciste
social traître est donc clairement on
voit que cette alliance potentielle avec
les communistes voir cette réunification
elle devient de plus en plus compliqué à
faire et le clivage va se durcir entre
les entre les deux mondes est
électoralement parlant de plus en plus
cet essai fillot va regarder vers vers
l'est du côté des radicaux pour défendre
la république et pourquoi pas arriver au
pouvoir alors que du côté communiste on
reste en tout cas jusqu'au début des
années 30 dans une position dure pas de
compromis avec les partis bourgeois
l'arrivée d'hitler au pouvoir les
termine la première des grandes volte
face qui ce qu'en histoire des
communistes français
[Musique]
du jour au lendemain staline exige
qu'ils renouent avec leurs anciens
camarades pour former une coalition qui
doit barrer la route au fascisme
ce sera le front populaire qui triomphe
aux élections de 1936 l'ironie de
l'histoire c'est léon blum l'ancien
vaincu deux tours qui dirige cette
coalition écrit devient grâce au soutien
des frères ennemis communistes le
premier chef de gouvernement socialiste
que la france ait connu
[Musique]
le gouvernement fait la difficulté de sa
tâche
[Musique]
pour google
cette victoire commune des deux parties
issue du congrès de tours est couronné
par le vote de lois sociales
emblématiques comme les premiers congés
payés et la journée de huit heures
[Musique]
mais cette union sera de courte durée en
deux ans à peine avant que staline ne
change à nouveau son fusil d'épaulé
le pacte germano-soviétique de 1939
créer un fossé entre les deux formations
le rapprochement s'effectue en 1941
dans l'armée rouge engage une guerre
sans merci contre les hordes nazies qui
l'amènera jusqu'à berlin
[Musique]
en france même la part très importante
des communistes dans la résistance lors
donne un immense passe-t-il à la
libération leur parti est devenu le
premier parti de france
pour la première fois depuis la création
du parti à tours les communistes entre
au gouvernement
l'ancien mineur maurice thorez devient
ministre d'état avec les socialistes
mais aussi les gaullistes et les
catholiques sociaux le parti la cheville
ouvrière de ce grand moment d'union
nationale
pcf et sf you travaillent main dans la
main à l'instauration des grandes
conquêtes ouvrières de 1945 et notamment
la sécurité sociale
cette parenthèse oecuménique sa chaise
en 1947 quand commence la gare droite
[Musique]
staline il ordonne communiste français
de se poser résolument à tous ceux qui
soutiennent amérique
une fois encore ils obéissent sans
broncher
ils sont renvoyés du gouvernement leur
traversée du désert va durer trente cinq
ans
dans l'entre-deux-guerres il y avait
encore cette idée toujours d'une main
tendue vers les communistes la guerre
froide a clairement marqué une scission
notamment parce qu'à l'époque les
socialistes sont au pouvoir c'est le
gouvernant paul ramadier qui voit
l'exclusion des des communistes et donc
l'écart entre les deux parties c'est
clairement accru à ce moment là entre
d'un côté des socialistes qui sont dans
la défense de la république telles
qu'aller à l'époque qui lui dit
communiste qui vont s'installer de plus
en plus c'est bien dans l'opposition à
7,7 quatrième république
jusqu'à finalement des grèves
insurrectionnelles qui sont celles de
1947 ça ça a clairement créé une
fraction beaucoup plus durs entre les
deux partis politiques dn aussi qu'ils
vont rester pendant longtemps qu'ils
vont mettre plus de 20 ans a
véritablement être être dépassé
pendant toute la quatrième république le
parti communiste est ostracisé les
socialistes de la et ses filles au
compte parmi les plus violents c'est
d'ailleurs guy mollet leur patron qui
déclare les communistes ne sont pas à
gauche ils sont à l'est
l'isolément du parti et qu'on paie et
même marcel cachin notre vieille
connaissance de tours n'y peut rien
[Musique]
ce qui me fait le plus de peine c'était
le penser on nous conteste le titre de
français alors que nous étions les
représentants les plus authentiques de
ce pays il est plus qu
il faut attendre la mort de staline en
1953 pour que les choses changent
[Applaudissements]
nikita khrouchtchev lui succède il
dénonce immédiatement les crimes de son
prédécesseur
khrouchtchev et le visage soviétique et
souriant de la détente qui s'instaure
dans les relations internationales
grâce à lui les communistes français
redevienne fréquentable
ça tombe bien car les socialistes ont
maintenant besoin d'eux les institutions
de la vème république les ont rejeté
dans l'opposition
pour revenir au pouvoir l'appoint des 22
% de français qui votent communiste
laure est indispensable
françois mitterrand est l'artisan de ce
rapprochement pour l'ag il faut que le
nouveau parti socialiste soit la kz2 la
future majorité ce nécessaire encore
parce qu'il faudra bien équilibrée et
location en distance et sept autres
forces capitale de la gauche quel parti
communiste puis enfin tout simplement il
faudra bien google la ténacité de
françois mitterrand un raison de la
timidité des deux appareils les grandes
retrouvailles officielles ont lieu en
1972 et elle suscite un immense espoir
au sein du peuple de gauche pour sceller
leur alliance pc et ps rédiger un
programme commun l'entente s'est fait
sur les nationalisations la diminution
du temps de travail et l'augmentation
des aides sociales autrement dit la
réforme pas la révolution dans les
années soixante dix les partis qui
simule le programme commun n'ont rien à
voir avec les partis de 2921 le parti
communiste n'a plus rien à voir avec le
parti de 1921 par la conception de
l'internationalisme mais plus du tout la
même si les partis qui se proclame
encore internationaliste mais qui en
aucun cas n'envisage d'abolir les états
et les nations les noms des parties se
sont maintenues mais rien de
l'orientation de l'époque on s'est
maintenu en tête
et pourtant dans les mots au moins la
gauche unie des années 70 ne lésine pas
pour renouer avec l'esprit du parti de
jaurès
celui qui n'accepte pas la rue
la méthode ça passe ensuite
celui qu'il consent va à la rupture avec
l'ordre établi politique sur votre soir
secondaire avec la société capitaliste
celui là je le dis il ne peut pas être
adhérent du parti socialiste
il ya un moment on dit ce qu'il faut
dire effectivement les congrès se gagne
à gauche donc il faut faire des rappels
l'objectif socialiste la perspective de
l'abolition du capitalisme
même françois mitterrand dira ça un jour
de grand vent en 1971 qui n'est pas pour
la rupture avec le capitalisme ne peut
pas être adhérent du parti socialiste
est ce qu'il y croit en tout cas il ne
fera pas donc qu'est-ce qu'on applique
qu est ce qu on croit possible ça c'est
extrêmement compliqué il ya toujours la
nécessité de se retremper un peu dans
cette légitimité de reprendre les textes
que valider quelques mois jean jaurès
quelqu'un comme jules guesde
effectivement ces 10 militants qui se
revendiquait de cette perspective la
star de changement de boîte de
production et de l'arrivée à un mode de
production communiste bon après est-ce
qu'ils y croient encore en tout cas leur
action ne niera pas dans ce sens là quoi
quelques années plus tard françois
mitterrand est élu président de la
république et quatre ministres
communistes entre gouvernements
mais l'expérience concrète du pouvoir va
très vite diviser la belle unité des
deux parties héritier du congrès de
tours
[Musique]
à partir de 1983 mitterrand tourner le
dos aux éléments de socialisme que
contenait encore le programme commun les
communistes se sentent trahis et claque
la porte mais contrairement à 1920 et
socialistes ne les attendront plus
l'hommage rendu à jean jaurès par le
nouveau président lors de son avènement
nora scellé que symboliquement l'unité
retrouvée
[Musique]
non
hautmont
eh bien
[Musique]